so you want to get into data science
right
well you're in luck because i work as a
data scientist
at untitled company wait
i work as a data science ad untitled
company
[Music]
hey guys welcome hey guys welcome to
another episode of joe oh god damn
guys welcome to oh my
hey guys welcome to another episode of
droma tech
now you might be wondering why am i in
my room well that's just how things are
going to be from here on out so
quick little update um i had to remove
my
day in the life video uh you know the
one that got me most of my views
i had to take it down because i violated
some policies
so that's why it's gone but today we're
gonna be talking about something
different
we're gonna be talking about how to get
a data science job
at a you know a large company like
friendster
or myspace something like that first of
all what is data science because i have
a feeling a lot of people have
you know misconceptions about data
science so if you do i would suggest you
to check
this video i made with um engineer truth
so yeah check that out and hopefully it
will give you an
understanding of what data science
actually is or what my role is alright
so let's get to it to the five tips on
how to plan a data science job
number one tip do an internship and have
a technical degree
how i got my first hands-on experience
on data science
was my internship and i did my
internship in a large untitled company
and um how i got that internship was uh
was i just had a few software
engineering background which you can see
uh you can see my other internships on
the previous videos
but yeah i had a few internships that's
software engineering and
my degree is in cs i never touched data
science before
so that's the thing so the easiest way
is to get an internship and then usually
they will give you a full-time offer
right after so here are some examples of
good degrees to have
cs software engineering economics
statistics math uh just engineering in
general like system engineering
uh maybe even environmental engineering
just anything with the word engineering
in it
they would you know demon as technical
and they will give you an interview all
right second tip
learn sql or sql i'm not sure
um so when you're going to start your
work as a data scientist
no matter where it is you're always
going to have to write sql because you
got to get the data somehow
no matter how fancy your you know python
is and stuff like that in the end
usually most companies set up their
infrastructure so that you query data
using sql
why because it's an easy language and
even like analysts or like
business intelligence people they use
sql so you know you'll probably have to
use sql too
because it's just easier for them and
then because they set up the
infrastructure like that you'll have to
use that too
and you also should learn sql because
all of the interviews
i got that was related to data science i
had a sequel question
let me show you an example of question
so i found this
take-home exam and i will change it a
little bit so that
the large company which is not the
original untitled large
company but another large company that
might or might not be related to
transportation
gave me this take-home exam so i'm going
to whip it out
so for example what they would do is
they would give you a schema
and they would give you a schema for
example you see id client id
driver id city id client rating driver
rating and stuff like that
and then the question would be something
like for each of the cities
san francisco and los angeles
calculate 90th percentile difference
between actual and predicted
eta for all completed trip within the
last 30 days
and then what you do is you have to
write queries for that
yeah i'm not gonna go through the answer
but
you should that would give you an idea
of what kind of query you should run
tip number three learn about success
metrics and tracking metrics
that is very very important and it's
kind of hard to learn because it's more
about
product sense so why is it important
it's important because
when you become a data scientist you
will be the expert
on your team on data right so imagine if
your team
is like at mcdonald's and you know
you're the main data scientist
then you're the one that will know where
everything
comes from like all the data sources and
also what to measure
for success because you're going to be
the one that the pm's ask you like
okay how do we know we're doing a good
job how do we know that the introduction
of these new hamburgers
that they're actually successful and
making mcdonald's a better place
for people you know sometimes it's easy
sometimes a lot harder to define these
success metrics i'll give you an example
taking from the same take-home exam so
imagine if the youtube creator app uh
in case you don't know what the youtube
creator app it's uh it's an app
for youtube creators like myself and
when you click on it
you could see like how many views you're
getting you know and how many
watch time and like what video is
performing on what comments you're
getting it's basically a tool for
creators like myself
so that's basically what the youtube
creator app is so imagine the youtube
creator app
is being redesigned you know they're
adding ctr metrics they're adding
better interfaces and they have like a i
don't know just better user interface
like a whole facelift
how do you know that the redesign was
successful
and what are the success metrics and the
tracking metrics all right let me talk
to you about the difference between
success metrics and tracking metrics
success metrics is usually the one that
the whole team cares about you know
they're always seeing growth usually at
a startup
it would be like how many active users
you have for example notvine.com
founded a startup called notvine.com
where you can share 6.1 second videos so
imagine not vine.com
i would care about how many active users
like on a daily basis
how many unique people actually open the
app you know i would care about that
would be my success metrics because
that's the main thing i care about
for now and yeah and then tracking
metrics i want to make sure
you know that they're actually you know
one real people or two having a good
time on my app
so what are the tracking metrics so that
would be for example let's think about
it um
i want to know if they're actually
watching a lot of you know videos
so tracking metrics can be watch time
per active user
and then or maybe just watch time in
general and then another thing can be
like how many videos
are they watching you know i want to
make sure that they're not just opening
the app and doing nothing
and then also let's see another tracking
metrics would be you know how many
uh how many like force quit do they have
why do i care about that because i want
to make sure i want to track the
negative stuff too
like are my like are my apps being uh
buggy like if they are and they keep
force quitting
then maybe the reason why they spend so
much time on the app
is because it's really buggy right so i
have to track these things to make sure
that it's not buggy
basically you want your metrics to be
non-cheatable and represent success on
your company
and then the next question after asking
like
how would you you know define your
success metrics it would be how do you
test it
okay so here's one thing you need to
know you need to know about a b
test you need to know about control
groups and experimental groups
and like how many people do you need in
them enough so that
uh enough so that's statistically
significant that you could see the
differences
but also to reduce risk of having a
shitty product
that you launch right because imagine if
you're the the launch of the new product
or like a feature that you built on
notfind.com is incredibly shitty
you don't want everyone you don't want
the whole 50 of your users
to be exposed to that experiment right
so you have to think about ways
to uh to make sure you don't risk that
but also to get
enough information that's statistically
significant all right tip number four
learn ipython r tableau or excel
or whatever to manipulate visualize and
interpret data
so why do you need to know all this uh
to be honest in my personal
opinion a lot of people like to use
ipython r because they actually look
really
you know uh technical and coding
intensive
but you know honestly i see a lot of
good data science
only use excel right they just grab the
data using sql
they manipulate it using sql and then
they just put in excel to visualize
things
because the impact is not how technical
you are
but how well you communicate those
findings and how well it
into product recommendations now i'll
talk about communication later
why do you need to learn all of these
because you know you have to manipulate
data sometimes sql can't cut it
and you need to visualize the data
because you need to communicate them
later
so so imagine you have a lot of data and
your company let's see
let's go back to mcdonald's so what do
you do you do an exploratory analysis so
imagine you're mcdonald's and you have a
bunch of data
about your sandwiches your your
hamburgers and stuff like that
so what the first thing you can do you
could you know use it
to download all the data manipulate them
group them by like you know hamburgers
or day of the week and stuff like that
and you could discover a lot of things
using that
and how would you do it you would use
either tableau excel r or python to
manipulate things right
because you want to answer questions
like all right which day of the week
um we have the most sales and then which
hamburgers
uh have you know which hamburgers are
the most popular
but then you could also say like which
hamburgers actually have the highest
profit margin plus
you know sales like so which one gives
you more revenue you know and stuff like
that and then
which ones are actually losing money
because apparently when i work there
uh ice cream every time they sell ice
cream they're actually losing money
because
employees didn't know how to you know
stop putting ice cream so
they filled it up too much so they try
to teach us how to put ice cream
but only put around it and leave a big
void in the middle so that they save
more ice cream
i never did that because i cared about
my customers so i want them to have the
best ice cream ever even
if mcdonald's losing money just saying
so this is why you have to learn
uh stuff like ipython r and stuff like
that yeah
honestly it doesn't matter which one
just as long as you're fast
and you're correct at you know creating
these uh
visualizations so yeah so in the end use
any of these technologies
to show your results to interpret them
and yeah so that's why you need them all
right number five
you have to learn to communicate really
really well because the whole point of a
data scientist
is to communicate their findings right
because if you don't communicate your
findings no one will know and if no one
will know it's not gonna
it's not gonna flourish into anything
it's not gonna forge into any products
learn how to do public speaking you know
because you're going to be doing a lot
of presentations
you're going to be talking to a lot of
people so a lot of cross-functional
partners a lot of people
like pms engineers and all that you're
going to be talking to them all the time
and you'll be presenting to them learn
how to write better
because you can't be presenting to
everyone in the company
but you know whatever you found is
valuable for maybe for another team
so how do you do that you write about it
you know you write powerpoints
you s or you write an article within
your company you write a post write an
email that's pretty important too
because like um writing is a very good
medium to reach as many people as
possible
especially at work learn how to make
interesting powerpoints
because uh when you're gonna be
presenting to people or when you're
gonna be presenting you know
uh your article you want to have graphs
and stuff like that
and then you won't you don't want it to
make it boring you want it to make it
obvious what they're looking at
i mean that's all i see a lot of data
scientists they have like graphs with
like a [ __ ] ton of like fancy crap
but i can't interpret it like i look at
it and there's [ __ ] ton of bars and like
colors and stuff like that
but what am i supposed to look at dude i
don't have attention span
you know just like a video creator you
need to you need to get your attention
within the five second
that's the same thing with work if
people don't want to read your [ __ ]
you're not going to have any value added
to them because they didn't read your
post
so make sure that when you present a
graph that it tells exactly what you're
supposed to tell
so enough information and it's obvious
what you're trying to say
and it proves your thesis so we have
this thing
actually i just say that i don't think
it's actually saying but here's the
thing
if you made an interesting analysis but
no one is there to read your analysis
did you really make an analysis
food for thought but yeah and then bonus
uh last one uh learn predictive modeling
so this is not super required
because um well it's funny because most
people
they optimize on this learn predictive
modeling whenever they think data
science because they think data science
is
really
related to like forecasting or like
finance
finance it would be pretty important
because the whole goal of your
of your job is to make more money and
how do you make more money you predict
the future
so so that you can capitalize on it but
for us as like a product data scientist
predictive modeling isn't that important
but it's good to know and it makes you a
little bit cooler
so yeah so it might be useful when
you're like forecasting goals and stuff
like that or when you want to build
recommendation systems on your product
but it's not super important but it adds
credibility
and also you know so that you can tell
your friends that you do modeling
all right so yeah so that's about it
that's five tips on how to land a data
science shop
at an untitled large company
and yeah i hope i hope that was useful i
hope that was great
this is pretty short because i don't
want to go through the details of it but
if you have any questions
um you know comment down below and i'll
try to answer it or i'll try to make
another video later on
so yeah so don't forget to like this
video if it you know added value to your
life
and also subscribe if you like my videos
and uh yeah peace out thanks for
watching
bye